AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
OTHER CITY SLOGAN.
OTHER CITY SLOGANS.
TONIGHT'S HONORARY GUEST
HAILED FROM AUSTIN, TEXAS,
WHOSE UNOFFICIAL CITY MOTTO
IS KEEP AUSTIN WEIRD.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF OTHER
CITIES HAD SIMILARLY COOL
SLOGANS SO GIVE ME AS MANY
NEW CITY SLOGANS AS YOU CAN
IN 60 SECONDS, AND BEGIN.
TOM.
>> KEEP MIAMI ON VALTREX.
>> Chris: POINTS.
CHRIS.
>> DETROIT, [BLEEP], DUCK
MOTHER [BLEEP].
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> KEEP YOUR LAWRENCE, KANSAS
OUT OF MY UTERUS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
STEVE AGEE.
DALLAS: KENNEDY-FREE SINCE '63.
>> Chris: POINTS.
CHRIS CUBAS.
>> BOSTON: AH, GO [BLEEP]
YOURSELF.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> KEEP QUEBEC FULL OF
DELIGHTFUL MARIONETTES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
STEVE AGEE.
>> MAUI: WE'RE ACTUALLY AN
ISLAND.
>> Chris: POINTS.
CHRIS CUBAS.
>> SAN ANTONIO: Y'ALL HEARD
THAT NEW KID ROCK RECORD?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
STEVE AGEE.
>> STOCKTON, I ONCE [BLEEP]
A GIRL THERE.
>> Chris: IS THAT JUST SOMETHING
YOU ARE SAYING?
YEAH, POINTS.
CHRIS CUBAS.
>> ORLANDO: WHERE METH MEETS
MICKEY MOUSE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.